[Arabic recitation]
Ash-hadu an la
Muhammadan
[Arabic recitation]
Akbar.
nastaghfiruhu.
[Arabic recitation]
May yahdihillahu fala mudilla lah.
rasuluh.
Ya ayyuhalladhina amanu ittaqullaha
haqqa tuqatih.
[Arabic recitation]
Ya ayyuhannasu ittaqu rabbakumulladhi
khalaqakum min nafsin wahidah.
[Arabic recitation]
nisa'a.
Wattaqullaha Allah and let it be
in Allah can I you Rocky
but
Yeah, I love you
and I love you talk Allah.
It took Allah and
call and said it down.
You sleep a man him.
Why you have to him do you know
about him?
When you talk Allah and I saw him I got
faster faster and faster.
I'm about to find out what happened to
get out of Allah.
What kind of heavy heavy Muhammad said
Allah and let it be with him.
What shall we do more than that to her?
What kind of Muhammad be that?
What kind of be that Allah Allah?
What kind of Allah Allah be in the
house?
I'm about to
for your call Allah to Allah
What kind OF KARIM?
WHAT KIND OF BE THAT MUHAMMAD be that?
I mean be that Muhammad be that Allah
Allah be that Muhammad be that Allah
Allah be that Muhammad be that
Allah Muhammad be that Allah Allah be
that Muhammad be that Allah Allah
[Arabic recitation]
The third chapter of the Quran
one of the most important chapters of
the Quran.
The prophet said Allah and let it be
with him urges us to recite Surat
al-Baqarah and Ali Imran
constantly
and to study its meanings
and to
find ourselves between their verses.
He tells us sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that these two chapters on the day of
judgement for those who learn them,
those who implement their teachings,
those who are in constant revision,
review, reading, reciting of these two
chapters,
that these two chapters on the day of
judgement will come for that person in
the form of giant scores, swarms of
of birds
that will
cover and provide shade
and provide solace for
their reciters.
In this chapter
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has dedicated Surah Ali Imran
to jihad.
The whole chapter.
The whole chapter is about
the struggle
between good and evil.
The first half of the chapter
is dedicated to al jihad
bil qawli wal lisan.
The first half of the chapter is
dedicated to fighting in the way of
Allah with knowledge
and with the tongue and with speech.
And the second half is dedicated to al
jihad bis sayfi was sinan.
Jihad with the sword.
What usually comes into a person's mind
when they think of this.
Now,
fighting for for sake of Allah.
Defending the truth,
defending the weak,
DEFENDING
[Arabic recitation]
This is something which is an obligation
upon every single Muslim to their
capacity.
Meaning,
that every one of us is to be a victor
of truth.
We here in
the current place and time that we
exist,
we are not in a place
where we
are called to physical fighting and
arms.
We are called
to the defense of truth and the
alleviation of doubts regarding our
religion.
[Silence]
He tells us that Jihad is two types.
Allah mentions
Jihad as two types IN THE QURAN.
HE TELLS US THAT fighting to defend the
truth
and the people of the truth is always
two types.
There is that defense.
There is that battle that takes place
with knowledge,
with statements, with the tongue. And
there is that battle
that sometimes is resorted to the sword
and physical iron.
He says, "However,
any person
any person who is not part of one of
these two types of Jihad in some way,
he is dead weight on the back of
humanity.
He is dead weight on the back of
humanity. Every one of us
is called to rise to the occasion of
defending
our religion. How do we defend it? We
are not in a place of war, of physical
war. We're not in a place where we are
called to physical arms. And in many
ways, that is the easier
of the two types of Jihad.
We, you and I, when I say you and I,
there is no distinction
between
"Oh, that is the domain of the scholars.
They're the only ones responsible for
that. I can kick back. I don't have to
do anything." As long as you are part of
the Muslim Ummah, and you reap the
benefits of being part of this great
brotherhood and sisterhood in Allah,
you are responsible
to be a carrier of the truth in some
capacity, in some way, even if it is
just for you to uphold the Quran and
Sunnah to the best of your ability in
your own household.
To uphold it for something greater than
yourself.
A man who does not live for something
greater than himself will die for less
than himself.
No man
who is not willing to die for that which
he lives for, he is not alive.
He's never been alive.
This idea that, you know, life is really
about you get a job, you make money, you
go on vacation two, three times a year,
we take pictures, and then when I get
old, you know, I'm going to be whole
It's going to be great. There's going to
be a little bow tie That is not
how life works. How does life work? You
are here for a few minutes. You make
your choice. Where are you going because
you only have one of two possible
destinations.
You will go to paradise
or you will go to the hellfire. And
neither of these two options is a place
that any person is forced to go.
Every person that enters paradise
has made a conscious decision to go
there
and has put in some effort to go there.
And every person who is dumped through
the gates of hell has made a conscious
decision to go there.
Our prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells us
Kullu ummati yadkhulunal jannah illa man
abaa.
Illa man abaa, ya'ni illa man
asao abaa.
Kan ma bidda ruh.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
meaning any human being who is born
during or after the era and the epic of
Muhammad Sallallahu alayhi wasallam is
all part of his ummah.
Every one of my ummah will go to
paradise except for those who refuse to
go.
REFUSE TO GO. WHO would refuse to go to
paradise?
And so the companions said, "Who would
refuse to go to paradise?"
Imagine a person insists, "I will not go
to paradise. I insist." This person
insists, digs his heels in, he must go
to the hellfire. What kind of person
would make such a decision?
Our prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said,
"Whoever obeys me will enter paradise.
And whoever disobeys me has refused to
go."
go.
And so upholding this truth,
defending it, protecting it, and
protecting its people is a
responsibility on every single one of us
to his capacity.
My capacity in defending the truth may
be different than yours. My position may
be different than yours, but we all have
a position and a part to play.
And that is that we are to learn the
truth
and that we are to defend it
in hopes that Allah will choose to allow
us the honor
of dying for and upon it.
That a person lay on his deathbed and
Allah allow him
[Arabic recitation]
his body. This is not something that you
can take without earning.
This is not something that is a
conscious choice you make on your
deathbed. This is something that you
must live upon in order that Allah will
give it to you at that critical moment.
[Silence]
And so,
we are to be very wary, very
vigilant
because
if we are not actively defending our
religion by learning it, teaching it,
implementing it, propagating it, being
patient upon it, if we are not doing
that,
know that those
who
are against this religion will
constantly be straining and struggling
to infiltrate it. How is it infiltrated?
How?
Well,
in Surat Ali Imran, Allah tells us one
of the ways.
THAT IN THE TIME OF THE Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam in Medina,
that
there were some of the people of the
book, of the Jews of Medina, that they
had come up with a plan, a plot.
They would send people who are
considered to be respectable men in the
community
to go and pledge allegiance to the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam and
accept Islam.
And so,
they would have a respectable person, a
person who is known for his wisdom,
known for his
for his fairness, known for his
intellect, known for his objectivity.
He would go
and pledge allegiance to the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam and accept
Islam.
That's the first part. The second part
is
after a day or two or three or a week,
he would leave Islam. No explanation.
That was the plan all along. To enter
into Islam, to practice it to a degree
that is reasonable. He'd make salah with
them, he'd sit with the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he'd sit
with the companions, he'd be one of
them, and then, suddenly, he would
apostate and leave Islam without any
explanation.
Why? To weaken the resolve of the
Muslimin. That is why.
How does that weaken your resolve? It's
something that is almost beyond words.
It's beyond words.
When a person sees this,
look at this respectable good man that
I've known since I was a kid or my
father knew since since I was a child.
This is a And then he comes and accepts
Islam.
Those people feel a sense of pride.
And they look at that and say, "See,
this is the truth.
Such a man would accept Islam." And then
the person leaves Islam suddenly.
And the idea that is being telegraphed
is,
"Well, such an objective
fair-minded
person
must have seen something that turned him
off of Islam.
Must have seen something. Must have
heard something
that caused him to leave this religion."
Not knowing that that was the plan all
along to weaken what?
Now, a person who would see this
wouldn't necessarily leave Islam with
him. No.
It would just weaken his resolve a
little bit. This is what the scholars
refer to as a shubha.
A shubha, something that is doubtful.
A doubt
that creeps into the heart.
And so we have one doubt that is not
resolved and another and another and
another and another until finally the
person has so many unresolved doubts
that their Islam is completely gone or
barely even there. Just the shell of a
Muslim after that because this person
was not active in alleviating those
doubts, getting to the bottom of those
doubts.
And we, you and I, right now, we live
literally in the belly OF THE BEAST.
RIGHT HERE, THIS IS the mega factory,
the assembly line of these doubts.
Doubts that we can almost not even put
into words.
You read the Quran that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala will punish
the oppressor, will give victory to the
oppressed. Then you look around and you
see
that this is not playing out in the way
that you expect. You look in the Quran
that a person who commits such and such
sin will be punished by Allah. You look
and that punishment is not happening.
That Allah will
reward those who do such and such. And
you look around and you see that that
reward is absent. Why? Because of a
misunderstanding of the Quran and a
misunderstanding of what you are seeing.
These doubts,
they are the death of a person's a
person's resolve.
And so, what are we left with if we
don't actively work on this?
We are left with a half measure.
Probably the worst situation to find
yourself in. A half measure, hesitation.
Hesitation kills.
What do we mean by hesitation?
Half-stepping.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT FULLY COMMITTED, but
we're not fully uncommitted.
We're not fully there, but we're not
fully away. So, we're just kind of in
this middle ground, in this gray area.
AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
What does the hesitation
in the obedience of Allah look like?
Hesitation
that causes you to
lose out on the dunya and to lose out on
the hereafter. Hesitation.
What does that hesitation look like?
Well, we come to salah, but we don't
really put a lot of effort into making
sure that I make my salah with
everything in me. We we make it.
And so, there is hesitation.
There is hesitation in our obedience.
There is hesitation in our
and our refraining of disobedience.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, he urges
us, he teaches us, he tells us,
He tells us, "Oh, you who have believed,
enter into Islam
full measure, entirely.
Entirely give yourself to Islam. DON'T
HESITATE.
DON'T HESITATE.
IMAGINE A PERSON who hesitates
in
doing something that is critical and
dangerous. This person may hurt himself.
Hesitation will ruin
an individual. Will ruin whatever you
set out to do.
If you have come to the conclusion of
doing something, you set your sight on
it, and you do it. You fulfill it. You
walk that path.
And you do not look back.
An interesting point
about entering into Islam entirely.
Al-Jassas,
he has
a book that he mentions an interesting
point regarding this issue.
He says, "You look at something a
lion pursuing a gazelle.
And you notice that
essentially the gazelle
it is faster than a lion.
HOW DOES THE LION CATCH THE GAZELLE?
How does a shaitan catch the believer?
How?
How does a shaitan overcome the
believer? How does that lion catch the
gazelle? You know why?
Because the gazelle doesn't just run.
It constantly looks back to see what the
lion's doing.
How close is it? Is it closer? Because
he's terrified.
AND SO BECAUSE HE'S CONSTANTLY worried
about what the lion is doing, instead of
just committing to the run, the lion
catches him.
And such is the believer.
When you walk that path to Allah, don't
look right and left and question and
maybe or maybe not or is this right or
isn't it right or am I correct or am I
incorrect? That is not how you commit to
something. You commit to it and you go.
Straightforward, EYE ON THE PRIZE. DO
NOT look right, do not look left, do not
wander, step and focus only on the
moment that you are in.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT TOMORROW. You don't
have tomorrow yet.
And don't chain yourself to the past.
It's already done. No one can change the
past. The only thing you and I have, THE
ONLY THING you and I have is this moment
right here. What are you going to do
with it?
And the next breath, that is a package
that you're not allowed to open yet.
You have to wait.
You have one moment, focus on this
moment only.
Can I sustain this forever? How can
Don't worry about that. Focus on this
moment, do it the best that you can.
Keep marching forward. Don't look
around.
Don't hesitate because hesitation kills.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Ash-hadu
Muhammadan
rasul
Hayya ala salah.
Hayya ala falah.
Qad iqamatis
Qad iqamatis salah.
[Arabic recitation]
Stand shoulder to shoulder.
Align your shoulders and your feet with
the shoulders and feet of your two
neighbors on either side of you.
Straightening the row is part of salah.
Still
qulubukum
[Arabic recitation]
rabbil alamin
Ar-rahmanir
Maliki yawmid
Iyyaka na'budu
nasta'in
[Arabic recitation]
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah.
Brother and sisters, please do not
leave. I will have a very important
announcement to make.
And you will be happy that you stayed
around to listen to this announcement.
And have a seat, please. Just it will
take no more than 3 minutes. So, please
stay with us and listen to be part of
this history that we are trying to make,
inshallah.
I want to share with you a tremendous
news. Alhamdulillah Rabbil Alamin.
We have been able to acquire one more
acre of property on this street.
[Arabic recitation]
you nothing. Just be enthusiastic.
Takbir.
[Arabic recitation]
something that's going to enable us to
expand our Rahmah Academy the way we had
envisioned.
It is going to be additional acre at the
end of that street, which brings us to
the edge of the river road.
Again, you have to really visualize to
understand that our plan was to see if
we could acquire enough property to
expand Rahmah Academy and grow its
the the levels of the classes that we
can do.
And Alhamdulillah, the footprint, the
two acre is all is the same space like
this masjid is built on. Just envision
this. It's about basically two acre
here, and we're going to have another
two acres over there. We acquired the
first acre about three years ago. This
is the last piece that we have,
Alhamdulillah, that makes the put the
puzzle together. The best part of this I
want to share with you
that this is a donation from one of the
families amongst us. Takbir.
[Arabic recitation]
dua for the family.
husna wa sifatikal ula an taghfira lahum
wa an tataqabbala minhum hadhihis
[Arabic recitation]
minhum warzuqhum ya rabbal alamin.
husna an taghsilahum min
[Arabic recitation]
Just give me a couple of more minutes so
I can finish the rest of it.
Our job is not done, right? Now we have
the footprint, that the space. We have
to build on it. And we have a waqf that
is already established for the Rahmah
Academy and everybody is encouraged to
donate generously for that waqf. There's
a separate account. Brother Jaber can
put that money into that bank and
inshallah that will enable us to make
the classrooms usable from the existing
building and the mobile home
space that's there modified so we can
use those for the classes inshallah. So
it's going to be expensive but it has to
be done and you can make it happen. Now
let me just also thank
None of this would have been possible
without the effort from Tayyab. He has
worked on this thing to put this
assemble together this lot for at least
a year. So I just want to thank him
personally from bottom of my heart that
that
determination, that commitment that
really made it happen and jazakallahu
khairan Tayyab.
Now let me just go to the other other
announcements. Fajr tomorrow inshallah
is going to be 5:00 a.m.
Isha tonight is going to be at 8:45
p.m. And we have a potluck tonight
inshallah. Bring your best dish and
share with the community.
Masjid cleaning is tomorrow inshallah
after Fajr. If you can spare the time,
please come and join inshallah and to
help us out.
The Rahmah Academy, Academy is right now
is enabled to offer the fifth grade. So,
again, takbir.
This is something that is happening
right in front of you, brothers and
sisters. Few years back, we had only
first, second, and third grade. Now we
are up to the fifth grade, and we have
enrolled people in there now. Kids
already there. So, inshallah, it will be
a very successful year. So, continue
making
dua for us and also contribution to the
to the to the Rahmah Academy.
so, inshallah, we are fully staffed, and
the classes start on Monday, inshallah.
donate generously on the way out.
[Arabic recitation]